5, c'est la fin des
cours à cette école secondaire
de Rouyn-Noranda, mais la
pour Louis-Charles Chauvette.
Il rentre chez lui
va se changer, puis sa mère
le reconduit au travail.
élève de première secondaire
- J'avai faire,
ça fait que je me suis dit :
je vais travailler.
de travailler au Super C.
- Du hau2 ans,
l'élève de secondaire 1 est
caissier dans une épicerie.
vendredi de 17 à 21 h, un total
ures par semaine.
- C'est juste correct,
puis comme ça, ça me permet
de faire des activités les fins
- Parce que tu travailles pa
les fins de semaine, c'est ça?
- Oui.
où tu dis : là je suis plus
fatigué?
- Non.
- Non?- Ou le lendemain, à l'éce
quand tu finis tard, tu finis àe
lendemain à l'école c'est plus
difficile?- Avec la pénurie de -
d'oeuvre, de nombreux employeurs
se tournent vers les jeunes pour
combler les postes vacants.
On voit de plus en plus
et 14 ans au travail dans lesrÀr
emploi, Mathéo Déry s'est fait
embaucher dans cet
élève de première secondaire
- Une annonce Facebook que
j'avais vue, justement,
où ils cherchaieisse.
CHRISTEL GROUX
propriétaire, Boucherie des Praz
- Sylvain, mon conjoint, quand
il l'a vu, parce que Mathéo
à l'époque et tout ça,
un jeune déterminé, il a dit
Je ne peux pas ne pas l'engager.
- L'adolescent, qui vient
tout juste d'avoir
mois, de juin jusqu'à la fin
de son contrat, en
Une façon de gagner un peu
d'argent et de combler ses temps
libres.ncontexte de pandémie, ds
comme ça, c'est tout le temps
amusant, justementde revenusde s
justement, c'était plaisant.- Qc
cet argent-là? Ou que tu vas
faire?
- Bien j'en épargne un peu,
des petites dépenses avec ça,
e reste.
- Son travail a été grandement
apprécié.
- Mathéo était très social,très,
donc ça allait super bien.
Puis, moi, ce qui ement, c'est
qu'il connaissait déjà un peu
la viande, il cuisinait, ça fait
gêné d'aller au devant des
clients es
choses.
- Il n'y a pas d'âge minimal
pour travailler au Québec.
Les enfants de moins de 14 ans
autorisation écrite de leurs
parents. Le père de Mathéo
n'a pas hésité.
- Le travail peut être positif.
C'est pas juste quelque chos
qui peut être ennuyant puis
obligatoire, mais il y a moyen
peut se réaliser, qu'on peut se
dépasser, qu'on peut apprend
qu'on peut avoir du plaisir
à faire et être fier de nous.
- Les jeunes Québé
travaillent de plus en plus.
Le taux d'emploi chez les
a pratiquement doublé en 20 ans
pour atteindre 38
Les données sont plus rares pour
les jeune étude pue étude pue é,
6 % des élèves de secondaire 1
travaillent chez un employeur
qui n'est pas une entreprise
de secondaire 2.
Mais en Abitibi-Témiscamingue,
ces taux sont deuxale.
MARIE-CLAUDE LACOMBE, dg Actione
- Ce qu'on voit ou ce qu'on
entend, c'est qu'et sur
le marché du travail de plusen .
- Travailler dès un jeune âge
peut avoon autonomie,
sa débrouillardise, améliorer
son estime de soi.
Mais il faut tenter de maintenir
un équil
- Au-delà de 15 heures semaine,
ça commence à faire beaucoup.
Les risques, c'est des risques
d'épuisement, de diminution
du rendement à l'école ou
au travail, la fatigue qui
s'accumule.
- Le plus grand risque,
c'est le risque de décrochage
scolaire, parce que c'est
attrayanececececececececececec
un salaire pour pouvoir
s'acheter des choses.
MARIA EUGENIA LONGO, prof, INRS
Chaire recherche jeunesse Québec
- Ça peut amener des avantages,
le fait de travailler en
parallèle aux études également.
Même s'ils font quelques heures
par semaine, ça peut amélior
la réussite et la persévérance.
Donc c'est l'équilibre.
- Pendant l'été, je faisais à
peu près du trois jours semaine,
lundi, mercredi, samedi.
Puis pendant l'école, je faisais
juste le samedi, en fait.
J'avais mon sport le matin puis
je venais travailler l'après-
midi.
- De faire une demi-journée
ça durant les
études à 12 ans, on est vriament
confortables avec ça moi puis ma
blonde. La boucherie, elle était
quand même très conscienteil étt
étudiant puis le travail numéro
un de Mathéo, c'est être
étudiant.
- Comme il a apprécié
sa première expérience, Mathéo
s'est trouvé un autre emploi
à la billetterie d'un centrees .
Une dizaine de ses amis ont
aussi un travail.
a qui sont
pas rendus là encore puis c'est
correct, ils n'y ont pas pensé.
Mais il y en a d'autres qui...
La plupart de mes amis, c'estnut
qu'ils voulaient. C'est surtout
moi, je pesen, qui les a fait
déclique
Mathéo puis je vais aller
travailler."
- Est-ce que t'as un projet?
Qu'est-ce que tu fais avec cet
argent-là?
- Bien, je le mets dans un a
compte puis je l'économise pour
plus tard.
Ici Olivier Bachand,
Radio-Canada, Rouyn-Noranda.